all right news now i-team finding
distribution capacity is
outpacing the number of covid vaccines
nevada is actually receiving from the
federal government
the i-team's david charns in studio here
now with the numbers and david at the
current rate
it's going to take some time for all of
us to actually get vaccinated
yeah a lot of time right now clark
county can vaccinate up to 92 000 people
a week
that number expected to rise as more
private partners sign on to get the shot
but at this pace
do the math it would take 26 weeks to
vaccinate all of us here in clark county
once
remember though you need two doses both
clark county commissioner
marilyn kirkpatrick she's the chair of
course and congressman stephen horsford
say this timeline will accelerate as the
federal government sends more vaccines
to nevada
right now our state is getting just 42
000
doses a week and that's actually up from
36 000 last week
we rank near last in terms of the number
of us getting vaccinated
but kirkpatrick telling me today the
county is ready and waiting
we have all the pieces in place we just
really need more of the vaccine
and we'll be ready to go we have to put
a all
of government approach to crushing this
virus
which means using all available avenues
including
the defense production act as necessary
to
get more vaccines and all of the
supplies that are necessary
so right now this is who is eligible to
get the vaccine health care workers
adults older than
70 public safety workers and then what
the state calls frontline community
support including what
our kristin drummond was just talking
about teachers heading back to the
classroom at the end of the month now of
course not everybody wants this vaccine
kirkpatrick saying about 70 percent of
us living here in clark county have
expressed interest
that is still a million and a half
people brian and david what about nevada
as a whole 42 000 doses a week frankly
doesn't sound like a lot yeah it's just
not it's the federal government that's
allow
allotting those numbers and both the
chair and congressmen
say more vaccine is on the way with now
the bidet administration
actually buying more pfizer and modern
vaccines
but with forty two thousand doses a week
it would take more than a year at this
current pace to vaccinate everybody
in nevada and again that's just for that
first dose we need to
brian a pace that clearly needs to be
picked up thank you david